all right welcome to a very special
edition of a beginner breakdown this is
the season finale and what I have inside
this box contains the meaning of life
yeah so I showed one of my co-workers
Darcy what was in this box and she was
taken aback and then I'm like yeah you
can't handle what was in the box and
then this is a true story
20 minutes later I saw it in the break
room crying because she had wasted over
20 years of her life I heard you if you
are not ready to see what is this fax do
not proceed all right so so everybody's
like I know I don't know what the menial
life is I know what it is right it's got
to be just being a a happy idiot right
happy idiot
that's the secret right you think
positive thoughts positive things come
your way all right so so I played this
game my senior year of high school I had
the white pieces and I sat next down to
a smiling goofball okay he was so happy
everything's great
so okay I got the white pieces and all I
want to do is wipe the smile off his
face all right so here I go efore he's
like I'll take my knife for a little
spin here all right take my knight and
now he thinks he's doing great I got a
pawn and now boom I'm the one who's
laughing so Mitch about seven is also
check me so you gotta realize that you
know being happy and oblivious it
doesn't really work because you know
things are going against you the world
is everything and time times a big thing
it's going against you all right so you
got to keep that in mind here all right
so so what else we got
what do you think menial life has got to
be here how about money money
everybody loves money all right so so
everybody know who baseball superstar
Albert Poulos is all right after 2011 he
was on the top of the world right he hit
three home runs in a game three of the
World Series okay he's the best all
right we win the World Series
all right so Cardinals offer of 200
million bucks to be a cardinal for life
and he's like yo man I want to be a
highest-paid player all right so he
signs a 240 million dollar contract with
the Los Angeles Angels okay so he's like
oh man I got all this money and life is
great never mind that there's more taxes
and higher cost of living in LA but he
didn't figure that he just wanted to all
that gross money 240 million gross okay
so so so now obviously poulos hasn't won
nothing with the Angels he can't believe
a can't even bet 300 anymore so he knows
man it's gonna be bad they're gonna be
booing me off the field and it doesn't
matter how much money I have I can't
take that
so it's year 2015 and his contract is
back loaded so he makes he'll be making
a twenty nine million dollars in 2020
and thirty million in 2021 so everybody
thinks money is the answer look at this
so that's a fourth of his joy a forty
million dollar contract look at this so
he's like he's already trying to get out
of it it reads oh well well it reads
just trust me it reads blue ball says
I'm going to have to retire in the
summer of 2020 leaving over 50 million
dollars on the table because my my
daughter is so good at the Olympics so
I'm gonna have to just retire so he's
already trying to weasel out of his this
big deal so there's more to life than
money
does everybody understand that yeah all
right
all right so money ate the answer all
right so what else we got
well all right so we're all gonna die
can everybody agree with that all right
we're all gonna die so let's say ye Bob
what why don't we just man we just you
know just yes just be miserable you know
we're gonna die it's a realization okay
all right so sorry so I'm playing white
against this miserable miserable guy
this was back in 96 as well all right so
I'm white and we play the Petroff
defense okay so I attack his knight and
so he attacks my knight I take his
knight okay so so he thinks he has his
Queen on e7 okay so he plays the move
all right yeah you can't do that right
so but you touched your king so you have
to play something right so the only
legal move is here and then we easily
win his queen with a double check so the
King moves Knight all right so so this
is like a lot of people all right
you know something tragic happens in the
first part of their life and you know
tragedy struck you know there's nothing
enough to do all right so I got news for
everybody tragedy happens to everybody
you're not special unfortunately okay
and it's like we got to get up from this
okay so quick story all right before I
was you know just superstar you know I
worked at in the beer industry stocking
shelves at our grocery stores okay it
was an awesome awesome time here and it
was a lot of fun at first okay
but then you know management got in my
uh my way and stuff and you know it
became monotonous editor of like five
years of stocking shelves okay all right
so so I'm they're throwing boxes into
the baler all right everybody know what
a baler is it's a compressor that turns
all the boxes into basically one big box
okay and very sad very sad so if you saw
the look on my face it was like it was
bad so so I decided had two choices at
that time I could jump into
Beeler yeah just just add to the hope
all right you know I could just quit my
job and move on all right all right
unfortunately I didn't think at the time
what my third choice would be is when
the forklifts coming by put my foot out
and sue the company for a million bucks
okay that was the real third option but
anyway I quit my job and I became the
super story that I am okay so so so
let's look at how this guy does Oh
tragedy struck I guess I'll go on
because I mean you two you don't want to
actually uh you know end it so all right
let's see how he plays all right so he
stops to checkmate that's pretty good it
tax my queen all right takes takes all
right big h6 move Queen up Bishop up
Knight takes so so that pollen push is
that is that very scary no all right so
here you can easily stop it and then he
asked to be checked here so you just
gotta got to do it check so he goes back
take his stuff
now he gets his other H pawn going all
right so so big threats here this H pawn
that really easily stopped
so you're just PI Y give them any hope
wait when your opponent has no hope
don't let them get a glimmer of hope
well you got to make sure yep that's not
what Nietzsche would say he would say
Bernal is the sentence no hope ever
all right so obviously we have a
checkmate coming up here rook c6
checkmate game over all right so so
pretty sad pretty sad his uh his weak
attempts to make a comeback you got it
you got to be bold you got it you got to
just get it get it going on here okay
and true story I seen this guy he came
into the club one time 20 years later
but you know it's just it's a still got
the same expression on his face his life
never recovered so if there's something
bad going in your life
get over it get over yourself already
and get on with your life alright
alright alright so uh so let's see
alright so we don't wanna be a happy
idiot
and and we don't want to be the sad man
definitely don't want to be the sad man
alright so so who else can we be how
about you know we just be calm cool and
collected
unlike me and everything will be okay
alright so here's a game I actually play
I lose but that's okay we'll buzz
through to the part I want you to see I
am the in this position I am the black
pieces no one I look like I'm awesome
look at all my past pawns I'm the best
okay but this guy James Ellie didn't
play him if you know him he's got a he's
got a positive vibe going all the time
and he he's had you know stuff happened
to him but he's recovered everybody
recovers he's a positive person
he knows he's down but hey things can
happen I just keep cheap chugging away
and who knows maybe maybe good things
will happen okay so so here he goes it
moves this guy's so then I push my palm
I'm thinking I'm great alright so now
you bring this king up oh I'm so close
to getting a queen so he checks me
alright so sometimes you know you know
you can't stop bad things from happening
okay unless you make something great
happen on your own here alright so
that's what he's going to do he's just
going to make great things happen so
check check check
I'm I'm the happy area time like so so
the comeback is complete here check
alright yep he then get down he didn't
get down and I came back and won it all
good good for James huh so that's good
all right so let's see let's see the
next one here all right who wants to be
like keep up with the Kardashians that's
that's that's that's good what my life
could be as good as a Kim Kardashian say
Kanye West
man I got the best the best life okay
all right so so here's uh here's uh you
know I'm in chests life right I'm so
good I'm so good I'm in chests life so
so here up bring this up where I'm in
chests life just uh give myself some uh
credit here okay all right so look at
that look at that chest life October and
our good friend Julia oh yeah
all right so I'm in chest life okay so
I'm the best so so guess who else says
make coomer's in chest life I've got to
be in chest life none other then our
good friend in the chair all right the
Chairman okay
and he says I've got to be not just in
the same and it's just life but in the
same in the same spot as well all right
the Chairman okay so he's trying to keep
up with me you can't keep up with me so
don't even try so here you go here all
right so here it is so so white is a
national master Spencer Feingold and
here's Tommy I want to play like a
master - all right so let's see all
right so Spencer's like what's he like
what's he like so what's Spencer like
here let's see what Spencer forget about
it all right so so Spencer's like
I got a new car so he's like I'm gonna
get a new car
and it's like I'm going on a Hawaii
vacation I'm going on a Hawaii vacation
especially I'm buying a Picasso and this
guy doesn't even know the difference
between a Picasso and a piece of dirt
okay so look at what he got he can't
even get a real Picasso but he's paid
the same for it all right so so he's
like I'm gonna go get a bow so he's like
I'm getting a boat too all right so so
it's like I'm gonna get a few art well
I'm gonna get a get a brand-new wife why
not all right and so now he's like I'm
gonna get in a few with the neighbors so
this guy's like I'm gonna get in a feud
with the neighbor - all right so now
Spencer is so much better than this guy
right and and he's always a step ahead
so he can actually take this [ __ ] up
here because if black takes back white
takes the Queen and he's up a full piece
everybody see that and obviously if he
takes the bishop here if he takes the
bishop here white will take back with
the Queen they'll be down to a queen for
a bishop so now you can't but he thinks
I'm smart a la playa check here don't
worry about it if after check white
blacks here and now the Queen has to
move and then Queen back yeah come on
get with the program here all right so
so now the Queen takes so now the queen
is in trouble here so the Queen retreats
to h3 and now he's like oh you know I
heard my my idol he's taken some drugs
it's a rumor so I'll take a poisoned
drug here and then what happens you die
you're done you're finished
checkmate yeah it's over so so Keeping
Up with the Kardashians won it won't
work and
it's stupid your life in this position
was so bad you were probably drowning in
debt you had a you paid a million bucks
for a piece of dirt instead of a Picasso
you're finished man and you're probably
miserable so so don't don't try to keep
up with people because it'll never work
alright so so there you go alright so
what else do we have here alright so how
about I don't need anything right
because I have Batman in my life here
everybody likes Batman right Batman no
good good all right so so the thing
about Batman is you know you have you
seen Batman he's laying in the bottom of
the hole with his back broken and he's
all crying about it ok that's Batman for
you it'll be real alright but you're
like no no no Mike you haven't seen my
Batman I got the super Batman going for
me so this is this is Batman in all his
glory when a disaster strikes in your
life
excuse me sir what's going on where's
everybody going
yes yeah I'm leaving okay I don't want
to die not on my schedule today not on
my to-do list
it wasn't wake up make breakfast John
science experiment die not on it so see
he'll flee too he'll save himself just
like the king okay yeah yeah yeah you
can figure it out all right but
basically Lamia doesn't have your back
he's gonna leave the city and be as
miserable as everybody else okay all
right so what else we have all right so
who else anybody else got what's in the
box here what do you think is in the box
ooh okay is that number four through how
about being content content man you
could be content you know that's kind of
like like you know you just live in
chilling everything's good all right
I'll give you a hint like being happy
and getting money that might be a
byproduct of what's in this box being
content is the last thing you want to be
content lame boring and you don't
understand there's nothing to be content
about is if you've seen Will Ferrell and
stranger than fiction
you just sit there all day eventually
time gonna get you okay so so let's look
at this 86 year-old woman she think
she's got it all figured out
all right so so she's rich so she
decides you know what I'm gonna pay in a
sane amount of money to live on a luxury
cruise ship so so I mean it seems nice
right you know you take your Dramamine
take some vodka and just lay down and
and just let the waves go pretty nice
pretty nice but not really because look
at this if you read further in the
article here so she says she retired
she's been doing this for like seven
years
and and then then you have to scroll
down read the whole article to hear this
it says interestingly the serenity
cruise ship is actually the second
cruise ship she's lived on formerly a
resident of a Highland American laner
for three years
watch Tedder the lady made the switch to
Crystal when Holland discontinued their
dance host program so she got a whole
cruise ship cruise laying to crush up
their whole policy of the dance host
program because they did want to dance
with her anymore they're like sorry sir
so you're actually pretty miserable and
nobody wants to be around lame miserable
boring people okay so so unfortunately
she thought she had it all but but no so
being content is not the way to be all
right so what else do we have here then
so be rich Keeping Up with the
Kardashians being content happy idiot
sad man not the answers is there
anything left there's one more thing
unfortunately to give us all meaning in
our lives all right and and does
everybody want to see what it is here
all right
you know yeah what and I want to give
personal thanks to mr. Josh Graham for
uploading this video are you ready to
see the meaning of life I guess that's a
yes all right here we go here we go
it's a lot better with uh with with a
lot of volume though I will admit that
hurry
mm
all right so you ready for me to open up
the box it should be pretty obvious what
it is though after watching that clip
all right the meaning of life getting
glory by being awesome
so girls cheer for you people yell about
how great you are your men amis get so
irritated and befuddled by you and most
importantly so you have an amazing
reason to celebrate with your friends so
that is the meaning of life you don't
have to be Michael Jordan you don't have
to be a state senator don't have to be
the richest man in the world you can up
get it on a the coldest night on a
Tuesday just get that glory and you'll
be uh you'll be on fire all right so
that's what it's all about
all right and I have a perfect chess
game that also exemplifies this so in
this game this is also a game from well
1990s 1998 Ori I'm a high schooler I'm a
bishop the bird Cavaliers all right so
our season you know didn't shave up like
we want it to we were four wins four
losses and forfeit loss okay so all
right when you have no chance at the
playoffs all right but we're all in the
car and we're having fun we are all
right so so here we go we decided we're
going to play the last game even though
it's meaningless as they say and so here
we go so I get the white pieces on board
one a win on board one is worth eight
win on board two seven three six board
for five and board board five is worth
four points all right that's how you do
the math and the scholastic okay so
anyway so I start out a four play this
guy rated a thousand points lower rated
than me and you're like oh man you can't
get any glory in this game what are you
talking about but there's always a
chance for glory right there's no excuse
anybody can get glory
laughter it is awesome in this position
because it stops the night from coming
down here alright thank you
the Bishop h6 they never play f6 that
was like that that guy in the first game
he's so bad all right so so f3 great so
you just take it it worked out perfect
alright so I take this pawn with my
queen
no the bishop the long-range bishop is
protecting it that was smart
all right we got better than that I'm
better than that
all right so so he's threatening check
so I stopped it and now I take and
you're like what what happens if he
takes here Queenie 8 checkmate and I get
his rook just for the heck of it - I get
it all all right so he's smarter than
that
I probably pounded it too hard
so we're just playing so now he's
getting some checks he likes to check me
as you'll see he loves to check me even
though they do nothing so there I go a
four a five and now the joke's on him
you can't go to B seven all right so big
joke's on him all right so so you're
like all right you be a 600 big whoa all
right so so then in the car
everybody wins we're like yeah we're the
best we're getting all these great
Slurpees now because we're the champions
and then then next day at school they're
all like on the big ticker it's like the
bird chess team
crushes melville 30 to nothing and
everybody's like what does that mean 30
nothing but they're talking about us
they're like yeah thank God that means
they got to be really good you know so
there it is all right you can be anybody
so the meaning of life getting glory
being awesome
so girls cheer for your people yell
about how great you are your enemies get
so irritated by yeah they're just oh and
then you can celebrate something amazing
with your friends all right so that's it
all right so hopefully y'all learn
something and thank you all for being
part of the beginner breakdown for a
year this is a season finale and hope
you enjoyed it